hello everyone the reason I decided to
show this game is well I haven't shown
any game that features the Traxler
attack yet on my channel and the second
reason is I really like the title of
this game it's called Hills like white
elephants and I didn't really understand
why a game would be called Hills like
white elephants but I did find out and
it's pretty cool I will tell you why at
the end of this video so the game was
played in 1952 it was played in England
and it's played between s Morrison and
TK Hemingway I couldn't really find any
information on either of this guys so if
you were able to find any information to
share in the comments as I also enjoy
learning new things so let's see this
game we have E 4 by Morrison and E 5 by
mr. mr. Hemmingway Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to c4 detail in game a
Knight to f6 and here we have Knight to
g5 the knight attack and well this is a
famous variation it was it's played
throughout history old masters used to
play it with d5 and well he captures on
d5 is the standard line and well before
before people learned that Knight
captures a hundy 5 is a bad move they
even played this so black off and got
into trouble after something like Knight
captures on f7 King captures on f7 and
Queen to f3 and well the point is this
Knight can't help out with the defense
because it's pinned and well only way to
play this for black successful is to
play King to e6 and the engine plays
this for black without a problem but for
a human this is a I think this is
impossible to play for a human and you
know I won numerous games online against
the weaker players sometimes don't play
something like King to g8 and then you
can simply Jack made your opponent very
easily but at this after this Knight g5
move there is also a very very sharp
point the sharpest of lines there is
Bishop to c5 this is called the Traxler
attack it's named after Karl Traxler
he was a he was a Czech chess master
and well he was also known as a chess
composer and well this is extremely
sharp white is black is willingly
offering this f7 pawn and well here I
move like Bishop captures on f7 isn't
really considered that great for white
as after King to f8 this Bishop has to
move from f7 as after h6 86 the night
will have to move and the black will
simply capture the bishop so after
something like Bishop to b3 simply d5
and although white is still better here
this is this is actually quite enjoyable
for black there are ideas like Knights
to d4 followed by Bishop g4 and well but
black does get a lot of initiative for a
price of one point and and and some
somewhat in a compromise King safety so
instead of this Bishop captures on f7
after Bishop to c5 the better move for
white here is Knight captures on f7 and
this is what what more is in place he
plays Knight captures on f7 and this
comes with an attack on the Queen and
also on the rook and here black plays
Bishop captures an f2 with check this is
the this is kind of the point of the
Traxler attack and again the best option
for white here is to capture this bishop
and then well hope for the best
he does have to know this align pretty
well to be able to defend but obviously
white wasn't really sure of him himself
and he placed him to f1 and here we have
Queen to e7 getting the Queen out of the
way and of course offering the rook on
h8 but that's the whole point of the
Traxler we have Knight captures on h8
and we have d5 now and this comes with a
temple on the bishop on c4 now allowing
this light spur bishop and CH to come
into play with Bishop to g4 for example
we have a capture stand d5 attacking the
knight on c6 and the knight to d4 and
well this is very very unpleasant for
white as now Bishop to g4 is a
tremendous threat
well white doesn't really have a have a
good square for the Queen so here white
plays c3 this does attack this knight on
d4 but also it it creates the only
square available to the Queen
is this a Foursquare so we have Bishop
to g4 attacking the Queen and now Queen
to a4 check again not really going for
the check but this a Foursquare is on
the only available square for the Queen
Bishop to d7 going back with the bishop
with a temple on the Queen and not
allowing him to capture seek after sandy
for we have Queen to b4 offering the
exchange of Queens and also attacked me
to b7 pawn and here black plays Queen
captures on b4 we have C capture some
before and now Bishop to h4 as this
Bishop was under attack here on f2 and
here black is threatening night to the
c2 and this would win the rook on a1 so
white prevents this he plays a Knight to
c3
now if night the c2 White has this rook
to be one move and we have King to e7
and this is a very nice move it it
prepares rook to f8 getting group
getting Brooke into play as the White
King is on f1 we have g3 attacking this
Bishop here on h4 and now first black
plays Bishop to h3 which check the King
doesn't really want to go forward to f2
and he definitely doesn't want to go to
e1 as night the c2 would fork the king
and the rook so he plays King to g1 and
here black is completely winning
he plays Knight to g4 and with this
Knight to g4 move black is actually a
threatening a forced checkmate in 7
moves so how do you stop this well oh
the obvious threat is Knight to f3
checkmate you can't capture the bishop
on h4 you get Knight to f3 and this is
checkmate
so after Knight to g4 why decided to
this to prevent this he plays Bishop to
e2 this defends their DF 3 square black
captures the Bishop Knight captures on
e2 Knight captures an e2 and now black
plays rook to f8 and this comes with a
with a very nice threat of rook to f1
with checkmate and there really isn't a
good way to stop this for white so white
tries to prevent it and you know he
tries something
he plays Knight four but here like
simply
tonight with rook not with the pawn rook
captures on f4 and in this position mr.
Morrison resigned the game as G captures
on f4 is followed by a bishop to f2 with
checkmate so yeah but after this worked
for like I said Mr Morrison resigned the
game and this is why I really enjoyed
the title of this game Hills like white
elephants as Hills like white elephants
is a story by Ernest Hemingway and as
the story goes this guy he meets a girl
at a train station and they're waiting
for a train I think the Spain or
something and well he orders two beers
and he starts a conversation with the
girl and throughout the conversation the
girl mentions that the hills surrounding
the train station remind her of white
elephants that don't move and well as
the story goes on but this this really
this really has some similarity as these
two rooks rockin a1 and rook on h1 a
kind of represent mountains and but in
fact there are the two elephants that
never moved so this is this is what I
got from the title of the game maybe
maybe you have something better if you
do I also would be interested in hearing
it in the comment section so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
especially the title of the game and I
hope you enjoyed the Traxler attack if
you've never seen it before
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank y'all for
watching and I will see you soon